there have been many very good and some
less than great versions of the joker
but whenever people discuss potential
casting for batman's iconic nemesis you
can be fairly sure that willem defoe's
name is mentioned the foe was actually
in consideration to play the joker and
tim burton's batman and although the
role has eluded him over the years his
instantly recognizable features and
particular strengths as an actor still
make him seem like an obvious choice for
the role sure defoe is now in his 60s
and as such it might be challenging for
him to portray a supervillain spider-man
no way home of course thoroughly
debunked that idea in 2021 in that movie
defoe handedly reprises his terrifying
role as norman green goblin osbourne
who's just as off-kilter as the joker
but far more physically intimidating
what's more defoe's one condition to
revisit the role was that he'd be
allowed to do his own fight scenes as
anyone who's seen him gleefully
manhandle spider-man can attest the
actor still clearly has what it takes to
bring both the drama and the physical
presence and any super villain role he
chooses to play and as far as the
joker's requisite creepy laughter goes
the foe once again shows in no way home
that there are few who can match him on
that front
is it any wonder then that people are
once again boarding the defoe joker hype
train in fact one artist has even
created an image that shows just how
creepily effective willem defoe could be
as the joker
in this image by digital artist el
illusionista it's evident just how
easily willem dafoe could slip into the
role of joker the picture shows a
jokerfied version of dafoe with all the
classic aspects of the character green
hair red lips pale skin a wild grin and
a fashion sense that skews toward the
color purple it's clear that the joker
in the image is in the middle of
something since he has a spattering of
blood or perhaps red makeup in the
corner of his mouth then a fresh cut on
his forehead judging by the character's
fixed gaze and the snowy cityscape
visible in the background it wouldn't be
outside the realm of reason to assume
that he's locked in a rooftop showdown
with the dark knight himself all in all
this is a very impressive joker what
makes the image even more astonishing is
the fact that it's surprisingly close to
what defoe looks like in his everyday
life color pattern notwithstanding as
the last image of the artist's post
reveals the image of the foe as the
joker is based on a photo of the actor
laughing while the colors in the
background have been changed to fit the
joker theme it's clear that defoe's
features are the same in both photos
right down to the hairstyle and the
configuration of the lines on his face
even with the knowledge that defoe is
uniquely suited to play the villain it's
almost shocking to see just how casually
he can contort his face into a joker
worthy grin
the dafoe for joker fan casting has been
going on for quite a while and in a
january 2022 interview with gq defoe
noted that he's very familiar with it in
fact people have been nudging him about
the whole joker thing for years this it
appears has piqued the actor's
imagination and he's come up with at
least one possible scenario for tackling
the iconic role though as is so often
the case with the roles defoe picks it
come with a twist he told gq
there is something interesting about
like if there was a joker imposter so it
would be possible to have not dueling
jokers but someone that claims to be the
joker that isn't the joker defoe also
revealed his ideal dance partner for
such a movie and it's none other than
joaquin phoenix the star of todd
phillips joker defoe said and that kind
of opens up the possibility of an
interesting story particularly if you
had joaquin phoenix's joker and then you
had someone who is either imitating or
ripping off what he did i fantasized
about that but other than that i'm not
talking to anybody about it you're the
first one defoe of course was quick to
pump the brakes after sharing his vision
and he probably wouldn't discuss such a
project if it was actually in the works
what
still the idea of defoe's fake joker
going up against phoenix's version of
the real one is indeed intriguing after
all considering that phoenix won the
best actor oscar for his role in joker
why wouldn't a potential sequel double
down with not one but two academy
award-worthy jokers
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]